yes oh god it's so
ugly i don't have my shaders on uh
what are you doing hold up one second
guys
it looks like the garden has been
growing while i was away
new minecraft update there's one thing
and one thing only i care about
axolotls i'm going to find an axel oh
wait
oh darksven that's right
welcome you want to find an axle
who's making that noise i need to ride
the cake oh god this is so
weird to see without shaders oh
automatic sorting system does it still
work does it still work
oh god damn it
it still works baby yeah
okay thank god all right
oh god damn it i forget i'm rich so you
find axolotls further down
and that's where all the new stuff is in
this new update for those who don't know
you can go below y zero
yeah the hell is it is that oh it's the
hurricane
damn this is so trippy dude okay
down we go okay so we need to go to
oh god so far so now you can go beyond
bedrock it's basically what i was trying
to say
how cool is that i remember when i first
started playing minecraft
my first instinct was to just dig down
and see what's
down below like how far can i go what's
down there
all the mystery and i was very
disappointed to find bedrock so early
so i think it's a really belated but
welcome
update to go beyond where no man
has gone before we're on nine now so we
should start seeing bedrock
which we i guess don't anymore i don't
know what i'd
there's bedrock what the [ __ ] i've been
lied to
then what the [ __ ] what's the point
minecraft
oh i've definitely been lied to you're a
liar minecraft
but a geezer minecraft may what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this mojang oh god i'm
not a veteran anymore because i don't
know
what what what the hell is that
they changed it what is all they what is
all this
everything different but still same
where's my axolotl how do i go
how i'm going bang i think i know the
trickeroonie
maybe it's like the nether update where
if you've already been
underneath it doesn't spawn the new area
so maybe you have to go to like a new
area
to then get the update i don't know uh
let's go to the netherworld
darksven you want to come with me okay
cool you can come next time
wait couldn't you build higher as well
oh my gosh
can you build higher already no stop it
there's too much to check out at once
this is i'm
because i built these and i built them
as high up as he could
dang it i'm not gonna make it
oh that's pretty high actually
oh [ __ ] sake
here it comes pro minecraft landing
there it is this is so weird
what is my 12 chunks get out of here
how high i build
i can't what the [ __ ] is this update you
lied mojang you're
a liar oh god it looks so ugly
what did you do to my basement i want my
shaders back
okay ow all right let's try my first
theory
i'm getting i'm getting the x a lot
uh okay i think it's been a while and i
didn't make any signs
i think this way yeah
here's the thing i'm i'm really scared
about i'm playing on my hardcore
parkour level i have no idea what's
changed
there could be like demon smeamons out
there steven demon
i wouldn't know bing bang boom i'm dead
not gonna happen though
why am i so [ __ ] slow have i always
been this long oh i can run
it's been a while okay i'm rusty sheesh
okay here we go we got something
remind me to make science jesus christ
all right where are we now what the
bloody blue
oh i know where this is one of the first
portals i ever built
why am i here okay it doesn't matter
because we're gonna dig down
this is our little hole you're welcome
you're gonna find me an axolotl now
give me my axle model i want a whole
army
we already got somewhat of a cave
happening here maybe
perhaps we ex no stay on target axolotl
wasn't it a cave update i'm so confused
where are the caves
i've been lied to the oars are different
that's it
you changed the texture i could do this
in five minutes
what is all their nuggets they're
chicken nuggets
what's the point we waited for this oh
my
god oh even the coal
i mean it does look better i i guess i
caves update wow they're so different i
can't believe it
i hardly recognize where i am wow
all right we go down did they change the
look of the coal no
they were like the coal is good don't
touch it okay where are we
27 well ain't that a thing
man this is not what i wanted
okay where are we 16. all right will we
hit bedrock place your beds ladies and
gentlemen
sir you can't go beneath the red
red rock hey lap is different too okay
great i got to change my lyrics now
everything is outdated
fully stacked better right so far all
these updates i've done
is make all my songs outdated okay
no i'm not happy there's the [ __ ]
bedrock again
why are you why are you a liar mojang i
will go underneath you
i'm so mad i'm i'm so mad okay what's in
the update then what's in the update
part one goats axolotls
okay there are axolotls okay there's a
ton of stuff i just can't find it
there's lush caves oh to find the lush
cave
you will need to look for a zealot tree
on the
surface and they're underneath a zilla
tree
the li they're not present in the 1.17
update
what
[Music]
what did they add to the game i don't
understand
okay it has become clear to me that i'm
hugely disappointed
no i'm not okay yeah i am so what
so what i'm not allowed to have feelings
fine well i'm
i can still find the axolotl they spawn
in underwater cave or underwater
sea level okay cool no problem i will
find him
i just gotta hear water and killed i
maintain them how do i tame them
it will all work itself out don't worry
about it i'm going back home because
this sucks
i understand you know they're working on
the game
it's a lot of pressure that the game is
optimized on old platforms you know
minecraft is
pretty much on every single device you
can imagine
they want to make sure it's a fun
experience for everyone so
instead of delaying the entire update
they'll release part one
and part two and in part one they had
absolutely nothing
where are they
oh god oh [ __ ]
ah you're diet you're dead
you're dead for scaring me you
understand this
you can't run forever can he run forever
i'm bored i'm bored die
how am i how strong them
who are you again what's your name
i bet i had a name for you and i forgot
it
you don't have a name i guess i can name
you anything
that's your name all right we're just
gonna fly
it's raining we will spot an axolotl
eventually is this an axolotl
is this an axolotl is this
an axolotl i don't know if i show this
in the video but i built
i built this long
long long ago it's my spawner see they
all
idiots the fools it was a lot of work
mate
but they also get sucked eventually they
get sucked they will all get sucked
aren't they getting stuck sometimes it
doesn't work if i don't have the right
render distance actually
if minecraft new update broke my spawner
then i will i will be mad i will be
okay it's working yeah they're getting
stuck
yeah get sucked below
why 63 so i'm too high right now
can you make a spawner for them charlie
someone's figured that out by now
dude my base looks insane what the [ __ ]
am i looking at
no i'm so dumb i completely forgot i'm
out
i'm not doing this we're not doing this
here's some water
axolotl what is this tree dude
good update minecraft have you seen an
axolotl
okay cool i'm not sure i ever went this
far north
what's all this thing
a massive ravine so far the only thing
different
is the [ __ ] horse and it's paying its
pain
spain death trap
left thread
left trap
what candle i can make a candle
candle what
they're supposed to be glowy squids as
well but i ain't seeing them
oh maybe we can find goat if no axolotl
i will find goat
damn really be snowing out here hello
goat
i found one i found a goat
i did it no one will stop me and go
there he is you're it's a pal cat it's
an alpine
you're not a goat are you can you
pretend to be a goat for the video
that'd be safe oh thanks bro
oh sorry don't uh you have to die now
i'm sorry
when you're far away from go
[Music]
and you just want to go
but you really want an extra life
but you find a stupid pig god damn it
should call this video trying to find
out what's new about the new update
[Music]
okay so archers are still very annoying
can confirm go
[Music]
are you a go answer me you got three
seconds
it wasn't a goat mate
what do you mean new recipe what do you
mean
new recipe how is that new
honey and string makes candles
wow thanks mojang
bro rich boy
hey looks like i'm the rich boy now
no chess
guys
they said there was a goal am i crazy
maybe i'm looking for nothing
but they said they say it
it is it is goats i found them it's real
the minecraft update is real i knew it i
never doubted it for even a second
now what do goats eat cows sorry cow
go i found you
it looks so creepy oh watch out go
oh my god there's so many of you what do
you want golden carrot
oh you're a rich boy huh okay how about
some
raw iron no beef
[Music]
oh my god what do you eat weird goats
that's so cool we got goats now this
changes
everything this changes everything my
whole automatic sorting system i got
got updated what does go eat
in minecraft goats follow player they're
holding wheat valve fed we they enter
love mode and breathe you can ride it
what just happened did you guys see that
what was that all right we're gonna have
to grow some wheat
i didn't bring any wheat i didn't it's
fine we can
we can make some wheat look at me
you follow me now you're my sign look at
me
hey look at me look at me you understand
not the cow idiot got away from me
the we i am the lord i am your master
thank you thank you goat master 64.
there's so many weird goats all
different kinds of colors wow
let's make some more and make them make
love because i want to see baby
who attacked me they attacked me
what is wrong with them i'm trying to
bring you back to my
there we go all right you two will be
patient zero one
and patient zero two make a baby baby
goat now
baby go now it's done it is done it is
so tiny
it is so tiny look at it that's adorable
stop [ __ ] attacking me i will kill
you
okay so we have one glue now we're gonna
kill your parents
[Music]
what kind of meat do they drop it's all
right sorry i think i hit the chime
that's fine they'll forget as soon as i
give them weak there you go you dumb
you're so dumb but you will be mine
you're coming with me papa poots
yeah you have no parents but me
i am papa now papa foods
no witnesses follow me baby go oh god
it's gonna be so far
oh my god how far away did i go 3 000
blocks i have to
bring back three thousand blocks on
second hand
oh it disappeared what
oh my god that must be like a glitch or
something mojang
again mojin strikes again what the why
what is this
huh copper oh
oh what it do though
yo i found coffer what'd it do though i
don't know more copper
okay okay starting to note this
different what it do oh god i gotta
expand my ass system
dang it damn you emoji
i'm joking by the way okay here i'll
feed you
give it back okay cool
we found the goat check we gotta find
the axolotl next
that i actually want to bring home oh
more copper
i guess copper isn't that rare well i
want him a
beautiful
oh god i forgot how strong they are
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i gotta deal with this hold up
guys
where are the fireworks i saved your ass
give me fireworks are you serious
i forgot just how insanely ungodly
rich i am in this game let me check out
i don't need these
let's get rid of them crap
all right give me good price i saved
your life
yeah good price for life saved
is dark span okay dark sound okay no
problem
it looks a little gloomy not gonna lie
okay
look at this damn this will be
filled one day okay so we have raw
copper i guess i gotta melt it right
right bunky
[Music]
bunky
oh cap come with me i don't have a
regular smelter
i don't how do i do this i don't have a
ring
hey sorry i can modify the system i just
don't know what the output is
oh gosh i forgot my entire wiring
okay it should be melting copper now
[Music]
but is it distributing
yes let's check out the result
let's hope i didn't turn my trash can on
actually where's my trash shoot
here the output should come here
if i've done it right but it doesn't
seem like it damn it
it's clearly doing something i don't
know where they're going that's the
problem
oh okay they came copper
[Music]
okay this is new what do we do
we can make block of raw iron what
lighting rod we can finally make one oh
my gosh
yes that is a great update thank you
mojang
i'll make how many can i make i'm like a
couple
ah yes i feel so good all right block of
copper
which makes us cut copper oh
proper the problem i have which
is not a concern of you guys i don't
know but they these guys keep getting
struck by lightning
all the time and they turn into witches
and i hate it so
now we can redirect the lighting here
sure
[Music]
go here you can strike all you want
kind of want to see a firestorm
thunderstorm now just to see how that
looks like
no more witches out of my beaches
okay so how does that cut copper look
incredible
honestly it looks kind of cool ah
it looks expensive and block of raw iron
damn why so i think if i remember
correctly
you have to use honey let me try this
well let me check out my beehive which i
have not entered in like forever
but it took forever to build as well i
don't know all right
sorry bees don't be mad hey they don't
care
did all my bees die oh i think all my
bees died
wow okay whatever
they were just my companion throughout
this entire series
what the hell emoji you're supposed to
combine
the honey right because just like actual
copper uh it will
oxidize which makes it green which is
the weirdest thing to me
because in sweden we have a lot of
buildings filled with yeah wax now it's
waxed
it looks identical though but
it's waxed cool uh in sweden we built
all these
all our buildings and ceilings are our
copper because we thought it looked
beautiful
but no one knew you tell me no one knew
it turns green
we just have green ceilings everywhere
it's a it's like
what you didn't think ahead a little bit
all i know is
i look forward to check out what's more
on this minecraft update if you want
more
smash like show your support we're gonna
find that exo lotto if it's the last
thing
i do thanks for watching bro fix
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [ __ ] loose
i got something
just download it for free for free
download
[Music]
i got something for you
[Applause]
you